great to be here great to see all of you
in person
i'm going to be talking about deploying
autonomous service mobile robots and
mobility is going to be like the theme
that's going to be tying everything
together and in particular how do we
keep them autonomous okay so uh before i
get into
the how and the what i want to explain
why right and the y comes from the
vision that we share and this is of
course not a unique vision it's shared
by many of us here and maybe in fact all
of us here but this vision comes in
three parts right so i want to talk
about what this is right so part one the
deployers and the tasks
so the kinds of things that we want
these robots to be able to do are to be
able to do tasks like answer for a
groundskeeper which trees on campus need
to be trimmed right or
everyone at some point might want to ask
a robot hey can you please get some
aspirin from the cvs or the pharmacy
uh or a site or a homeowner um clearly
not in the bay area but somewhere in the
in the northeast would ask a robot can
you clear know from the sidewalk right
and uh any of us
could might in fact uh want to ask a
robot which stock on campus has free
food
and clearly the rumor i hear is that
it's like the robotic seminar which has
free food i could be wrong you can
correct me but i want to point out like
the key features of these things is that
we should not require a phd in robotics
to be able to deploy robots in fact i'll
go so far as to say you shouldn't even
require a bachelor's degree right
and the second thing is that the
mobility is going to be crucial for
doing these kinds of tasks effectively
okay all right so part two what are the
robots that we're going to deal with
right so the robots that we're going to
deal with is going to be quite varied
right you could have like a pre-built
ready-built robot maybe from a
hypothetical robots rs or in the future
you might want to like assemble robots
from parts from newegg robots and the
key features is that they need to be
affordable and they're going to have
limited compute and sensing it's not
we're not going to be able to come up
with algorithms which take in inordinate
amount of compute or have like very
careful specific requirements for
sensing so these are going to be general
purpose and customizable robots
part three the environments so kinds of
places where we want to actually deploy
these robots are going to be things like
university campuses or commercial
establishments or even homes right and
the key features is that these are real
human environments they're going to be
unanticipated characteristics like
whoever built the robot they're not
gonna be able to predict what your home
is like right
and uh because of this there's gonna be
variations with location and time right
so putting everything together the
vision really is to have autonomous
service mobile robots deployed by
non-technical end users in arbitrary
human environments performing tasks
accurately and robustly over extended
periods of time and when i say extended
periods of time it's not like going from
5 to 15 minutes i'm talking about like
years at a time like just having a robot
doing uh tasks in in our human
environments
so uh in my lab we like
uh putting things together putting all
the algorithms together actually sending
these robots out in the world and
actually having them do tasks uh here
are some examples of some of our robots
on the top left is the cobot which is an
indoor service mobile robot and the
bottom right is the spot which we're
deploying for tasks on the ut campus
scale and the top right is a fun video
where we put one of our jackals to work
and the reason why it's actually
carrying a trailer or pulling a trailer
is because at ut the robotics building
is actually different from like the
computer science building and the
packages get delivered to the computer
science building and it's actually kind
of a
it's a chore to like get these packages
back and forth so we were deploying our
robots anyway so we just put a trailer
on our robot and asked them to like do
package delivery between these buildings
and the fun thing is that these robots
are pulling packages which have parts
for other robots so the robots are
helping us build other robots so that's
fun right
now why is this actually a hard problem
first of all uh it's not
this whole thing it cannot actually be
done by just like advancing like a
single individual piece you need to have
concerted advances across many sub
problems you need to have good
localization mapping semantic
understanding task planning what have
you everything okay
secondly edge cases or things that we
like to as algorithm designers think
about yeah that's never going to happen
that's not true it's going to happen
right if you think that something's not
going to happen inevitably it will
happen right
and finally there will always be
something new new environments new tasks
new ways to fail right new ways to make
errors which you didn't even think about
right so there are many challenges
challenges to long-term autonomy and i
want to like spend some time today
talking about three particular uh
sub-problems in this long-term autonomy
one of which is robustness to
environmental changes the second is
anticipating and overcoming failures
unanticipated failures and finally
adapting to user needs okay so let me
first talk a little bit about these
robustness to these environmental
changes
so what i mean when i say environmental
changes what do i mean by these
environmental changes so if you go back
to these the video which i showed look
at what's going on around the robot so
in this indoor robot there are these
tables and chairs and most of the
observations of the robot is not off
like the static map or the walls or
anything it's about these movable
objects
the spot is being deployed in a scenario
if you look in the background there's
essentially like construction going on
similarly with the jackal there's
construction over here there's park a
parked cars or these cars could be
moving there's a lot of dynamics right
things are changing right and in the
context of all of this what i'm going to
be talking about is like localization so
essentially having a robot which can
robustly and accurately reason about
things like am i at the place where i
need to take a left to get to where i'm
going right is this a sidewalk that i'm
looking for is that the sidewalk which
is up ahead right so you need to have
reasonably robust and accurate
localization to be able to figure out
which part to take okay
so there are
at least two canonical solutions for
dealing with this problem of changes
right and they don't and and i'm going
to talk about like the two simplest
solutions might not necessarily actually
work right so first of all you could say
you know there's a lot of changes in the
world what if you just ignore those
changes what if you just like ignore the
things which you don't know how to deal
with right this is actually not going to
work very well because in challenging
environments what happens is that let's
say you have a robot you have a static
map shown in this red over here and you
have some maximum range of the laser
rangefinder of the robot
most of these observations are actually
going to not match the map in the most
challenging environments and if you
throw away everything you have very
little to go by okay all right so what
else can you do you can say well let's
just go out and remap the world when
things change right but that's also not
scalable because if you think about
these environments these tables and
chairs are going to be in different
locations roughly every 15 minutes
because there's a new group of students
working on a new assignment uh for the
sport which is being deployed over there
there's construction and like the
construction barrier is going to move
roughly off the order of like once a
month because it's making progress
during construction
the parked car changes you know whenever
people uh
park in different locations and then you
have more construction which is changing
right
so you can't really always
see that the world has changed and
immediately go out and remap everything
that's not going to be sustainable
solutions so what do you do right so how
can you actually localize in the
presence of all of these unexpected
observations right
so what you can do is like let's think
about these nature of these changes
right so to think about the nature of
these changes let's say we have some
observations from sometime step t0 you
have some observations from time step t1
if you actually correlate the two of
them you actually get some interesting
uh
correlation start to emerge so first of
all you have some observation which you
didn't expect to see but are temporarily
consistent over a short period of time
right
uh and then there are these other
observations which you didn't expect to
see and are actually not uh consistent
over time right so what these are what
we would call uh short-term features
right things which you didn't didn't
expect to see but are still consistent
dynamic features which you didn't expect
to see and also are not consistent and
finally we have what we call the
long-term features which actually do
match our long-term map right and the
key idea of the uh the first uh
one of these uh the first algorithms
that i'm going to talk about today
episodic non-markov localization is to
reason differently based on the nature
of these observations whether they're
long-term or short-term or dynamic okay
so how do we actually do this so we
actually come up with uh we try to come
up with rich probabilistic uh
formulations to actually deal with these
changes right so what we do is that we
start with the the standard dynamic
bayesian network for markov localization
you have the variables x0 from xn which
are the robot poses you have odometry u
through un and you have the observations
s13sn
and in particular in this graphical
model what's happening is that the
assumption is that condition on the
robot pose and the map the observation
should be entirely explained but that's
actually not true right so to account
for that what we do is that we extend it
using what we call varying nodes and
varying correlations and what's going to
happen is that the exact structure of
these varying
nodes and varying correlations is going
to be different depending on what's
actually happening in the world right so
this needs to be done as a real-time
inference okay
so how do you actually keep track of the
state of the robot so we have the belief
over the history of the robot poses okay
so first we apply bayes rule and then we
end up with a product of the sensor
observation terms and the odometry terms
so the thing to note is that the
odometry terms still obey mark of
independence right so the second part
can be written as a product of n terms
okay
the first part we need to do something
about right so here's the first part of
the insight we we first of all uh
factorize it out into like the product
of three parts which is the the
likelihood of observing long-term
features the likelihood of observing
short-term features and the likelihood
of dynamic features right
um in this initial work we actually did
not explicitly track these moving
dynamic objects so we actually uh
dropped this term but for the short term
features what you can do is that the
robot can actually reason about like
well what are the distinct sets of
movable objects right and then those get
grouped together and you have how many
ever
distinct sets of unexpected observations
there are right
and now what you have is that you have
this nice formulation where you have a
product over some non-markov terms you
have a product over some markov terms
and this approach this so how many
factors there are between here and here
actually is evaluated by the robot on
the fly so in a scenario where the robot
is deployed in a setting where
everything is explained given the map
there'll be no non-markov terms you are
left with essentially same uh plain old
markov localization whereas on the other
extreme where you have none of your
observations which match the map the
robot's essentially going to be
basically doing slap and this algorithm
is essentially automatically scaling
between the two extremes whether you
know everything or whether you know
nothing and then some points in between
okay so that's the general key inside i
want to share some uh some qualitative
results uh you can look at the paper for
more quantitative results but here's an
example of a scenario where there's like
movable chairs right and
the algorithm has actually
essentially reasoned about where are
these movable objects and what they are
and the different color indicates what
its classifications are so you can see
like the observations which match the
map showed in blue the map is in blue
the observations which match the map are
shown in orange the long-term features
the observations of these chairs shown
in purple are different locations every
single day so like day one day two and
day three the exact locations of these
chairs are different right and while the
robot is moving through these kinds of
spaces most of these observations are
actually uh not of the map so this
algorithm can be also
very beneficial when you're deploying a
robot in places like parking lots where
most of your observations in fact are
not static right and you can still
robustly keep track of what's going on
so this actual algorithm is actually
very powerful because it allows us to
deploy a robot on the ut campus scale so
i've overlaid uh the sparse long-term
map over a satellite image and what i'm
trying to show is that the map that we
use the long-term map is actually very
sparse most of the things that the robot
deals with actually just deals with on
the fly so we don't have to give it like
tedious information of like everything
in the world uh while it's running it's
doing uh this is actually a
visualization from a real run it's
trying to figure out which of its
observations match the long-term match
which ones are unexpected and it's
taking them into account right so the
long-term features provide the global
corrections the short-term features
provide the relative corrections and
it's like a sound probabilistic model to
reason about all of this so this is
actually the the strength behind which
we deploy our robots robustly on the
campus scale uh we can do fun things
with the the the mobility that this
allows like things like do lemonade
delivery autonomously on campus during
covert shutdown right but let's come
back and think a little bit about the
changes in the world right so i started
talking about the changes in the world a
lot of these changes in the world are
from commonly seen movable objects right
like tables and chairs
these tables or chairs are not actually
the locations of them are actually not
completely random right there's uh they
follow some common distributions like
think about these parking lots people
don't just park cars any random way on a
parking lot there's some common
distributions right can we have uh have
robots infer these distributions right
so that's what we're trying to do can we
learn a reason about these movable
object distributions over time
and this is essentially the idea behind
this algorithm called probabilistic
object maps where we're trying to
leverage long-term probabilistic
distributions of movable objects to
infer likelihoods of their observation
right so how do we do this
so there's here's a simple idea what you
can do is uh you can reason about the
likelihood of
observing a short-term feature
as the marginalization over all possible
poses o right uh that an object could be
and then you're considering the
likelihood of making a short-term
feature observation condition on that
pose right
this is not actually quite right
although it's getting to the heart of
the problem right the problem here is
that p of o is essentially uh the
likelihood of a single object being at a
particular pose like the distribution
over poses however
there's not just one card there isn't
just like one chair there's an unknown
number of these objects right and we're
trying to ask how likely is any uh
instance of them going to be at an
arbitrary pose right so we recast this
problem into something more akin to uh
occupancy right so what we want to do
instead is ask
given a pose how likely is that
arbitrary pose going to be occupied by
an object of that particular class right
so that ends up with a reformulation
where you have two variables r and c uh
c is just a classification which says
it's occupied
r is actually the pose and now we
actually have two parts to it the first
part actually says
um what is the likelihood of object
detection if the object were at pose
uh some pose and the second part says
what's the likelihood of that pose
actually being occupied by any instance
of this object we're not saying that
there's only one instance okay
so this actually uh
works pretty well
this this term over here is what we call
the probabilistic object map and we can
infer that using gaussian process
classification
we deployed this on observations taken
from the robot over a week um and you
can see like the inferred distributions
uh
are actually consistent with essentially
the the satellite view image of this uh
parking lot
and the thing to note over here is that
we're looking for consistency of this uh
the robot trajectory over time if you
use an algorithm which assume that the
world is static like uh cartographer or
legolone which are very good algorithms
when your world is static in an
environment like the parking lot where
things change they break down right and
you can see that there's no consistency
over time for them right so you can look
at the accuracy in terms like the of the
cumulative distribution function of the
errors and you can see that um our
algorithm the forms are actually a lot
more robust uh in these uh in these
cases when you have a lot of changes in
the world okay all right so this gives
you a flavor of uh some of the work that
we are doing on like building rich
probabilistic models to reasonable
changes in the world
um now is actually probably a good time
to see if there are any questions about
any of these things that i've been
talking about any questions
i'm going to take a sip of water value
questions
okay the next question clarification if
you go back to the previous
the uh
one word so that that integral okay does
this require some assumptions about
independent distributions like not every
object could be anywhere right yes a
chair isn't in a parking lot probably
yeah
assumption yes the assumption that you
have to make is that there is no like
relations between the occupancies uh and
we of course know that that's not true
but it's definitely an initial guess uh
we've thought about things like there's
relational uh
relations between them so for example a
table and a chair
are likely to be relative to each other
and the thing will probably move as a
set rather than like individually uh so
that's a good point right yeah okay
okay uh yes other question yeah so on
the following slide
uh it seems that en ml right is doing
quite well comparatively so what exactly
is the distinction between
uh the very good position very good very
good okay so form localization
interestingly has no long-term map the
only thing it has is distributions of
these movable objects okay eml uh the
previous algorithm which i spoke about
does have a long-term map so it actually
has a lot more information
so what happens uh is that you see these
cases where it breaks down the cases
where it breaks down is that it's really
struggling to actually do a joint
inference between like these movable and
these static objects right when it's
going between like uh when there's a lot
of cars and it's going between a row of
cars and none of it matches the map
right so so enml in this scenario has a
lot more information than actually this
uh form localization and the only map
that the form localization has is this
is just a probabilistic distribution
of movable objects that's it nothing
else
okay uh yes
how does form localization do when it
encounters things that are very much out
of distribution like someone occupying
four parking spaces with a single car
for example yeah completely out of
distribution uh uh
data will essentially have like almost
no corrections you get no corrections to
your baseline automatically um so it
just won't provide any corrections to it
a harder scenario is like if you have
like subtle errors like if you take the
entire parking lot and if all of the
parking lots space is moved by half a
space then you get this like uh very
subtle shift um but that's that's
actually definitely an edge case a
long-term match case yeah okay there was
a question there yes
yeah so
so what is like the form of all these
distributions because you had
marginalization i believe that you had
to make something
yeah so doing the exact marginalization
is computationally intractable uh so the
way we do the marginalization is that we
we concentrate on those poses which are
most likely to compu to contribute to
this distribution and then we use
sampling to actually uh estimate the
marginalized marginalized likelihood
okay cool uh yes one more question you
determine which poses are most likely to
contribute to that and then a follow-up
question is it seems like we need to
make some sort of assumptions about
the number of objects to some degree
right otherwise it wouldn't be a finite
markov model you would need to have like
some sort of like a dirichlet process or
something so how do you get around the
problem of how do we like have an
unbounded number of objects in an
environment
okay uh let's take the first one the
first one is a
we did a uh interesting thing where we
use a generalized half transform for
given an observation you reason about
the possible poses which could have
given rise to the observation and if you
have a model of your observation
likelihood like your your object
detector has some uncertainty from there
you can uh using the generalized half
transform you can get a sense of like
what are the space of possible poses
which could be consistent with the
observation so that's the answer to your
first part the second part is that we're
using gaussian process classification
so uh we're not necessarily limiting how
many cars there could be uh it can be
like how many ever
peaks there are in the gaussian process
uh classification the real limitation
there is like how big your kernel can
get in the gaussian process
classification and that really affects
your computational runtime okay right
yeah because um yeah since the kernel is
dependent on the points in your trading
set doesn't that put a bound on how many
points that's right it does not and in
inference then what happens is that uh
the kernel we don't actually uh
deal with the whole full kernel matrix
what we actually do is that we take like
uh block sub matrices of it and the
blocks in some matrices are chosen to be
in like the the same geometric location
a large window around it
okay and the idea there is like the
likelihood of this problem for a
different very far away location
affecting your observation here at a
particular location is actually going to
be quite small right so you can
do some like cutting off it's it's
similar to limiting like the bandwidth
of or the influence in your kernel
right okay okay cool let me uh come back
to additional questions uh once i have
at the end of the talk but uh these are
excellent questions right so the next
thing which i want to talk about is
essentially anticipating and overcoming
failures right so when i'm talking about
anticipating and overcoming failures
what do i mean by failures what could
possibly go wrong right right here's a
video here's a fun video oh no let me
can i pause it somehow
oops go back sorry
where's my cursor
all right um anyway i'm just going to
play the video what happens is that we
deployed the robot in the real world we
didn't stage the scenario it's just
something that the robot came up with
and you know this is a scenario where
the the consequence of failure is
actually quite high if it had made the
wrong decision and it like
accidentally hit the cones or if it had
like fallen over into the mud like the
consequence of failure could be quite
high
as a human if you saw that scenario you
probably wouldn't have taken the narrow
opening between like the the cones and
the mud you would probably have taken a
different path right why is why are
these robots doing these like risky
behaviors the reason why they're doing
these risky behaviors is because they're
not reasoning about the likelihood of
themselves making mistakes and this is a
flaw fundamental flaw right and uh the
the consequences of feeler can be quite
high if you're deploying your robots in
the real world here's another scenario
where the robot like arbitrarily came up
uh across an actual uh a fire training
uh scene where the fire department had
like live fire situations like clearly
if you did something wrong bad things
would happen right
okay so i've at least given you a couple
of examples from real arbitrary
deployments that um consequence of
failure is high what are the types of
ways in which these robots can fail
right so here's an example
where the robot's trying to uh drive
down the corridor it's supposed to just
go down the corridor however um
okay you can see my cursor here so uh
all right okay here uh the robot's
supposed to go straight down this
corridor clearly you can see there's
nothing there however the robot's coming
up with the plan shown in green where
the robot tries to drive all the way to
the right and then hug the wall and then
come back to the middle
what do you think is going on why is
this robot coming up with this crazy
plan and just not not just going
straight on the hallway what do you
think is going wrong
good direction yeah the reflections okay
so reflections in the ground robot sees
reflection on the ground and things oh
wait there's a hole in the ground got to
avoid the hole right what's happening so
this particular algorithm has clearly
made some assumptions that the world is
has lamborghini surfaces there are no
specular reflections of course this
assumption is not true and these
assumptions when they're violated bad
things happen
uh you can say like i have a better
algorithm which doesn't make this
assumption and i will say that no matter
what your algorithm has some assumptions
and eventually these assumptions are
going to be violated which will
currently lead to failures okay
so uh
what we what we instead started doing is
that we started thinking about
uh
failures in a different context which is
like given an arbitrary perception
function right um can you actually come
up with a higher order function which
when applied to this for this perception
function predicts
which parts of a sensed data is likely
to produce erroneous results and this is
what we call introspective perception
okay so there's at least two ways of
actually doing this uh without label
training data or like a human label
training data
uh the simplest of which is actually to
use supervisory sensing and what we do
here is that let's say your robot has
stereo cameras and you have occasionally
available sensors like the kinect which
only works in indoor environments okay
when it's available you can do
perception and planning using both the
kinect and using stereo vision
and you can uh and when you trust the
the kinect you can actually compare the
two plans and understand when the flight
plans are valid or when they're
divergent okay now here's the
interesting thing you can actually when
you're doing this uh processing from
stereo vision you can actually also ask
the the vision stack for which parts of
the images were processed to come up
with this plan and then when the plans
start diverging you can penalize that
part of the image which led to the plans
diverging and that leads to uh the robot
collecting this data of reliable versus
unreliable patches now using that you
can train this introspective perception
model and at runtime you can actually
come up with estimates of what is the
likelihood of your output um of your
plan being conditioned on things which
are which are erroneous right so this
allows
the robot to actually
learn to predict autonomously things
like these false positives like by false
postures what i mean is that the robot
thinks that there's an obstacle there
but there actually isn't an obstacle
there the introspective perception can
also predict what are the true positives
which are like the walls the true
negatives where there is indeed free
space and so on right
uh what's also cool is that if you so
the introspective perception is is a
deep neural network you can take the
second to last layer and if you think of
them as embeddings if you cluster them
uh with these failing samples you can
actually look at how many distinct
clusters there are and what's
interesting is that for this particular
algorithm we were able to discover two
clusters one of which which we knew
about which are these reflections and
then there are these other clusters
which actually interestingly had abrupt
surface transitions between two surfaces
at a corner but there was like a very
little texture at them right and that
was leading to failure so that's kind of
interesting okay
all right so this is one way of feeling
and this is one way of how you identify
failures what are different ways of
feeling right so
here's a video uh
i'm going to pause this video
um of orb slam uh running with a visual
stream running on this robot uh what
this algorithm is doing is it's trying
to build a sparse map in terms of uh
landmark locations these feature points
and also estimate the uh the robot's
location over time right the disclaimer
is that this is a actually under nominal
cases or slab is actually a very good
algorithm it can actually produce very
accurate results but this is actually
not a nominal case okay
um can anyone guess as to what's going
to happen
here based on what you're seeing on this
image
yes
build an app as it's going yeah like if
something changes in the environment
then like a previous map it's not going
to be validated okay uh that is true in
this scenario there's not going to be
any changes there's something else going
on in this image so you can see that
there's this like shadow going on over
here like what's what do you think the
shadow's going to do any guesses
yeah
uh it's going to perceive that as like
an object in its way and try not to hit
its own shadow
ah okay that's also a good hypothesis so
okay let's take that idea so what's
happening is that there's something in
the in it in its way the shadow what's
happening is that the algorithm extracts
features from the shadow the shadow is
not moving in the image space
and hence the the robot thinks that oh
wait feature is not moving robot must be
stopped
okay
where what's actually happening is that
the shadow is traveling along with the
robot right okay so how would you
overcome this uh this problem well one
thing you could do is like you could
write a shadow detector and like exclude
shadow detections but guess what there
are other ways of failing right this is
exactly the kind of thing that we want
to automatically have robots detect like
you can we want to have it detect like
reflections shadows
uh
uh lens flare glare and also like
features on movable objects right and we
can actually do this and i'll show you
how we actually do this okay so to
understand how we actually did this i
need to delve a little bit deeper into
how visual slam actually works okay so
to really distill it down to its core
what's happening is that we're trying to
come up with the likelihood of the
camera poses over time one two two t and
the feature landmarks in 3d
conditioned on these observed image
features and this is actually a product
of a joint likelihood over all of time
and over all of your landmarks the
observation the likelihood of an
observation of a particular landmark and
at a particular time step conditioned on
the robot pose as well as the landmark
location right and then you can uh
solve for the arc max but actually
maximizes the maximizing this log
this likelihood by varying this x and r
okay so the key part of this problem is
its observation likelihood right
and a very simple way of representing
this observation likelihood is to say
that your observations are drawn from a
gaussian distribution the mean of which
is given by image reprojection of this
landmark the predicted image
reprojection and the true observation is
just going to be corrupted by some uh
coherence uh sigma so this is just
assuming that your observations are
gaussian but guess what we know that
observations are actually not gaussian
so from this figure taken from this uh
uh
from you know bundle adjustment of
modern synthesis an excellent uh seminal
paper which way back then like showed
that if you had to synthetically draw
samples from this gaussian distribution
in blue right the kinds of errors that
you get is actually not at all
representative of the real areas that
you see in visual slam algorithms which
are actually a better fit to something
like a cauchy distribution right so what
we're trying to do using introspective
perception is like there's a slam
pipeline but what we're trying to do
separately is
predict the post hoc distributions of
these image reprojection errors okay so
that's going to be some arbitrary
distribution and we want to predict that
if we're able to predict that then we
can use them for three things right
first of all we can guide it in
selecting where in the image to pay
attention to we can tell it like where
not to pay attention to and we can also
say that if you're a little bit
uncertain you can actually take this
uncertainty into account when you do the
joint optimization to actually be robust
to failures okay
okay so we want to predict these
post-hoc distribution of these errors um
now how do we actually represent this
arbitrary distribution this is actually
non-trivial problem right so we actually
limit this distribution to a particular
class of functions and the class that we
choose are those
which can be represented using a loss
function applied to quadratics right and
a a a common choice a choice of this
loss function is a huber loss right
which has quadratic loss when the error
is small and linear when it's far right
so you can for different parameter
values of the huber loss you have
different uh shapes of these loss
functions right
however even with this uh huber loss you
normally choose like one parameter and
you assume that all of your data is
identically distributed right what we're
going to do however is a little bit
different the what we're going to say is
that the parameter of this huber loss is
going to be dependent
on the image right so this delta which
which gates when you go from quadratic
to linear is going to be a function of
the image and where in the image you're
looking at so we're somehow trying to
predict as a function of what you're
observing and where in the image you're
looking at what is going to be uh the
the gating between the quadratic loss
and hubellas right so that gives you
some idea of like predicting uh the the
distribution of these reprojection
errors okay
right so you can put everything together
so you have the stack of images you run
this through your introspection function
it gives you this value delta
which is then used for future extraction
and tracking and also for this bundle
adjustment so let me show you how what
happens between iv slam and orb slam
right so in the same scenario so first
of all ib slam rejects most of the
features on the shadow it's learned to
understand that shadows are hard
it inserts more features from other
parts of the image and then for things
which is uncertain about it actually
downwards right and that essentially is
sufficient to allow the robot to
robustly track its location over time
whereas the baseline still thinks that
the robot is stuck
um we also applied it on this algorithm
in other settings such as where you have
these reflections um
again these reflections are going to um
cause this monocular slam system to
actually have scale runaway which
essentially
shrinks the world and the robot
trajectory down to nothingness whereas
our algorithm is able to robustly keep
tracking the robot right um
and we've done a lot of quantitative
analysis of like seeing how much of a
difference this makes in different
settings uh the biggest difference that
we see is like in in what we call the
mean distance between failure so
um that is how far can this robot move
before it actually catastrophically
fails and there's actually a significant
improvement in in that value and the way
it's doing that is that
qualitatively you can look at what it's
picking up on so it's picking up things
like shadows reflections glare and also
movable objects like humans like it's
saying that if you extract features on
movable objects they're not going to be
geometrically consistent over time okay
all right so this gives you an
understanding or or a flavor a very
quick overview of like how we're doing
introspective perception to like detect
and overcome uh unexpected failures in
the world right all right let me pause
and see if there are questions about
this section so far
yes if you wouldn't mind repeating the
question because it's hard for people to
hear on soon goodbye yeah thanks
questions
okay no questions in the moment maybe we
can okay there are two questions all
right
yes how is the inverse model training
for the first approach that you
mentioned where you have like a
connect server that you can query yeah
so in the uh
the way we train it is that we can
classify so using the uh the kinect and
the stereo vision remember we collect
patches when the when the plans agree
and when they disagreed so you can think
of this as a classification problem of
like just saying these are the patches
where they disagreed and these are the
patches where they agreed so when they
disagree you can say that there's
something wrong in the image that's all
the training contains right you can do a
little bit better and when you say when
they disagree uh did the uh the the
supervisory algorithm take a longer part
or a shorter path in the sense like did
it think that there was an obstacle
there or they think that there was no
obstacle there so you get a little bit
more fine grain distinction there but
that's essentially your training data
and you're just trying to do a
classification of like how likely is it
that a particular image patch is going
to be of uh of these types so that's
that's the training
yes
network installation yeah yeah it's uh
it's essentially just a
fully computational for network or
whether the losses it's actually just
the classification loss whether or
whether the patches are uh consistent or
inconsistent patches
okay
yes it seems like the the features like
the features are like critical the
feature maps were critical in getting
this working so i'm curious if y'all
noticed that using like um more diverse
data so maybe data where like the angles
of the shadow is different throughout
the day help with the out of
distribution uh problem yeah uh so the
features that i use in this particular
algorithm we're on learn features
they're actually like hand core features
these are orb descriptors which are hand
coded we've also done the work with like
looking at like sift features and all
since then there have been a lot more
like the use of learned features for
draw slam uh we haven't tested with
those but we're uh we've at least seen a
couple of examples where for example
super point which is a learned feature
uh has uh some kind some some similar
kinds of errors that we see over here
where it makes like aliasing errors like
if you have a repeating pattern it
actually makes errors in like uh saying
like this brick corresponds to this
other brick and so on so it would be
able to pick out at least like aliasing
regions are actually difficult and
things like that okay so this approach
is separate from the earlier yes yes so
it's applying this general idea of
introspective perception of predicting
where in the image you're going to have
errors but we're applying it like two
different problems like uh depth
estimation errors and like feature
extraction and matching errors okay
right
yes
um
i think
these these improvements are really
impressive and it's really really cool
but it's not yet mean distance to
failures not infinite yet like what what
do you think are the the big challenges
that remain yeah so the question is like
um
these
these improvements are are significant
however they're not uh they haven't
solved the problem entirely what are we
still missing
um okay so there are a couple of uh
things to note one is that the training
signal for this iv slam is actually
quite weak right so we uh since these
features are sparse features uh when we
have when we're trying to predict these
post uh uh
post optimization uh reprojection errors
we have only very sparse uh training
information right and if we had a lot
more information we might be able to do
a better job of this prediction
so we have done this characterization of
like if you had the ground truth of
which feature uh which point of the
image led to actually errors and so on
and if you actually sorted your features
in terms of like errors and you came up
with the distribution and if you just
drop like the the the worst ten percent
what error would you get and so on right
so that's like the ideal case if you
knew exactly beforehand which features
had what errors you could just drop them
right so there's like a significant gap
between where we are at and what that
curve looks like um i think we need we
need a lot more sophisticated or ways to
like
glean information for training these
models than we are currently doing
i think there's a lot to more
improvement to be had there right yeah
right uh any other questions at the
moment
nope okay we can definitely come back to
this uh at the end of the talk right so
the the final thing which i want to talk
about is this uh the kinds of things
about like how do you adapt to user
needs right so here's a common way in
which we want to adapt to user needs we
want to deploy a robot on the campus
scale your campus has nicely manicured
lawns you don't want robots to just
barrel across the grass you want them to
them to actually stick to the sidewalks
right so how do you actually get robots
to stick to sidewalks well one thing you
could do is that you can actually
do semantic segmentation of your images
and then you could stick to particular
classes this actually
has a couple of problems and i'm going
to talk about two of them so first of
all if you do discrete semantic
segmentation you end up with the
scenario where sometimes you have like a
continuous distribution of going from
grass to
dirt and like grassy dirt in the middle
the discrete classes can fall somewhere
arbitrary in the middle for no good
reason that doesn't really necessarily
make sense secondly inevitably your
robots will discover new classes of
terrain which you didn't know about
right how do you deal with that well you
got to collect more training data right
that's not really sustainable right so
instead what we actually
did is that we came up with this
approach called visual representation
learning for preference aware path
planning and the idea here is that we
use unlabeled human demonstrations to
simultaneously learn visual embeddings
of terrains and also preferences over
the embeddings okay
so how does this work so during
deployment so you have an input image
uh the first thing that we do is that
using the camera extrinsics and
intrinsics we we compute a homography
which allows the robot to reason about a
synthetic bird's eye view of what's
happening around the robot right and
then given the synthetic bird's eye view
we extract patches from there and feed
it through this learned visual
representation function
uh to generate terrain embeddings and
these terrain embeddings are distinct
for different types of train which are
relevant for path planning right and
then each terrain embedding
via this learnt visual preference
function is going to lead to some
preference uh consistent costs so the
question is how are these learned visual
representation functions and this
learned
cost functions actually learned right
how do you do that right so as i said we
work with human demonstrations and then
the human demonstrations have for
example the robot the human drives this
robot from here to there right now this
is a part taken by the human you can see
the human follows a sidewalk but to the
robot from the robot's point of view it
doesn't know about these different types
of terrain all it sees is something like
this a part like this
this is actually quite useful in fact
right so locally what the robot can
hypothesize is that there's shortcuts
that the human could have taken but the
human did not take those shortcuts so
there must be some reason why right so
what happens is that the algorithm takes
a synthetic bird eye view around any of
those places where the human could
potentially have taken a shortcut and
then it essentially says
this image patch off the path where it
could have potentially taken the
shortcut and the human did not take that
and the on path there must be something
distinct between them we don't know why
why is different we don't know what is
different and how to uh treat it but
there's something distinct about that
right so concretely what that means is
that your visual representation function
should apply it on the anchor patch from
on path versus off path which is like
the uh this this dissimilar patch
there's there has to be some minimum
difference between these embeddings okay
secondly when the robot
moves on a trajectory if you look at the
same point in the world shown in this
green
square if you look at the same point in
the world from two different viewpoints
what you want is like the embedding of
that same location to be the same
because it's the same thing right so
this essentially encodes viewpoint in
variance so what we're seeing is the
representation of the same
location from different viewpoints must
be the same they must tend to zero right
so combining these two ideas together
you essentially come up with this
constraint that
the difference between the visual
embeddings of the anchor and the
dissimilar must be at least
delta v away from the distance between
the anchor and similar right and you can
come up with a triplet loss where
whenever this inequality is not
satisfied you can penalize errors to
that right and that becomes your
training to actually uh train this fviz
function give an arbitrary triplet of uh
the anchor dissimilar and similar right
and given a trajectory you can actually
automatically just pick random uh
triplets from that trajectory consistent
with what i've done okay
once you have this visual embeddings uh
the learning the jc is actually quite
simple which is the cost function all
you need to do is that you need to say
that the the cost function needs to be
such that the demonstration is actually
what turns out to be uh uh the the
optimal thing to do sorry i wouldn't say
the optimal thing to do i would say that
the uh the cost needs to be such that
they're consistent with the
demonstrations uh there might be other
ways in which uh you can actually
satisfy this this preference but the
preference needs to be satisfied okay
all right so this turns out to work
quite effectively with small numbers of
demonstration and just to give you a
sense of like how this works we took the
robot to the park uh we gave it some
demonstrations in a small corner of the
park where we drove it on on on this
gravel uh
trail and we just asked it to just
continue following the trail and the
robot just continued following the trail
right
you can see like this
this is quite a noisy environment where
there's all kinds of variations of like
dirt and grass it's not like hard
there's lighting changes
uh the ground is bumpy but the robot
deals with it it's able to continuously
follow the trail
okay so this is one class of ways in
which we deal with adaptation right or
you're adapting to user needs right so
what are some other ways in which we
want to adapt to user needs so one of
which is
let's say the robot is
navigating in an indoor environment
sometimes a robot might come across a
scenario where there's a locked door and
it might need to ask the human to open
the door to uh to let it through right
um another example is the social mini
games right these social media games of
like dealing with elevators or doorway
minigames where you know the uh
depending on which side of the door and
elevator you're on you need to wait some
distance away and let the others pass
before you go through the thing is that
it's hard to actually specify reward
functions for these kind of decision
making tasks right and secondly the
exact mini games might not essentially
be known a priori so um the elevator
scenario can differ depending on like
the specifics of of the lobby and so on
and you can only get a small number of
limited demonstrations to uh to learn
how to overcome these problems right so
the insights here is that it's easy for
non-technical users to give a few
examples
and the other thing is that this
reasoning this decision making can
actually be done on physically
meaningful quantities and i'll come back
to a little bit more about this physical
meaningful quantities but the the
general idea of the line of research of
this is essentially what we call physics
informed program synthesis right
so we've looked at asking the question
of can we synthesize programmatic
policies to do these kinds of things can
we repair these programmatic policies
and how do we actually iteratively
improve these programmatic policies over
time right so to put everything together
what we're after is programmatic
policies to perform decision making
using physically meaningful quantities
and we'll actually use smt solver aided
synthesis and repair to pull this off
okay
so concretely what we're doing is that
we're after a policy pi right which maps
from uh some states and some previous
actions to a next action the state is
going to be continuous it's uh it's an
outer product of things like the rn uh
times se2 like the pose of the robot
times other things right
and these are all physically uh sound
things for the example positions and
velocities of humans states of nearby
objects and so on right and these
actions are going to be discrete low
level skills to follow okay
so the way we do this is inspired by
this line of work on programming by
demonstration or programming by example
the most popular of virtual section
essentially flash fill where if you
enter like two columns of data in an
excel spreadsheet and you enter like
only part of the solution on like one of
the cells it comes up with a
candidate of a formula which predicts
like what the relations are so this is
really under the hood synthesizing a
symbolic formula which relates the two
of them right
and this approach has been done in other
pro in other domains like uh web
scraping done by sarah jason's right
so to pull this off what we actually
need is a language to do the symbolic
synthesis in right and this language for
robot action selection policies needs to
be both expressive enough to represent a
rich variety of these adaptable decision
making problems right while being
constrained enough small enough so that
we can actually generate these programs
right so how do we do this so first of
all one insight that we have is that
these action selection policies actually
have an innate structure to them right
you can think about like what are the
transitions that the policies make right
so maybe in the previous time step there
was a skill called go to in the next
skill this is from robot soccer you're
transitioning into kick and you can like
compartmentalize your program into these
potential transitions
the second thing to note is that each of
these input variables like the location
of the robot and the location of the
ball has physical dimensions right and
these mathematical operators they're not
just like blindly doing math they're
they're essentially coming
up with physically meaningful quantities
and physically meaningful expressions
right so that's going to be important
right so putting all of this together
um the language for robot asps that we
came up with essentially has a layered
structure for these policies at the high
level uh they use predicates which are
going to be essentially comparisons over
expressions and and parameters and like
compositions thereof
and these expressions are going to
include things like compositions with
unary and binary operators and so on
right
okay so how do we actually use these i
was talking about physically informed
dimensions like how does that actually
work
so
this language has a type system which
is actually very flexible and the type
system
encodes the dimensions in terms of like
the exponents of length time and mass so
for example if you have a quantity v one
which has exponent one zero zero this is
actually a length right and something
which is an exponent one minus one zero
so length raised to time raised to -1 is
speed right a vector of that would be a
vector velocity what does this give us
what this gives us is that now you can
take all of your mathematical operators
and you can annotate like what are the
type constraints that you have so for
example when you're doing additions the
inputs most must be both of the same
dimensions you can't add a length to a
velocity that doesn't make sense right
and if you add two quantities you end up
with an output of the same dimension
right
so internally what's happening is that
when you're synthesizing new expressions
you're synthesizing new quantities
physical quantities in the space of
quantities right so that's what's going
on right so something you can do is that
the roboticist can actually say that in
this domain you can limit the space of
what expressions are useful for this
doing this decision making so you can do
say say things like uh maybe you don't
care about uh the time derivative uh
greater than minus two because
acceleration is sufficient you don't
need jerk or something okay so to put
everything together uh what we're gonna
do is that we're going to we have this
algorithm called layer dimension and
from program synthesis ldips which does
enumerative search uh using these
dimension constraints on these operators
and constraints on physical quantities
to uh to actually limit the search okay
all right so
what are the demonstrations to this uh
in input so on the left is showing you
the gui that we use for giving
demonstrations for robot soccer so uh
there's a simulator running and at the
bottom like the human can choose what
low level skill to execute at a given
time step and can hit run the robot
starts executing and then the human can
um go back and forth and give it and
tell the robot like should be doing
different skills on the right is a
different gui that we use for giving
demonstrations for how to do social
navigation and the human can tell the
robot what low level skills to be
choosing okay so the end uh end of this
demonstration what you have is like you
have a sequence of tuples which says
that during the demonstrations what was
the previous action that you were doing
what was the state of the world in terms
of all of the the real quantities and
what is the next action chosen so given
this demonstration the first thing that
is done is that our synthesizer comes up
with a sketch of the policy of all of
the possible transitions that were there
in the demonstration
now the gating condition of like when do
you make these transitions needs to be
filled out so to do that it enumerates
possible combinations of these uh these
predicates to actually fill them in
right
and in these uh predicate there are it
synthesizes these expressions uh keeping
in mind limiting the scope of like the
physically uh sound expressions that i
was talking about and finally the
parameters are filled in using sat
modular theory so essentially all it's
doing is that it's saying that can you
find parameter values such that the
result of running the program is equal
to the demonstration right and if you do
this you end up with the full um
the solution so you have these
demonstrations where you start off with
the sketch the sketch gives you uh some
uh some holes where you need to fill in
these expression unknowns and now you
have parameter unknowns and then you end
up with the best fit set of parameters
and at the end of the day you either
have
a satisfiability score like how much of
the demonstration you satisfied uh with
respect to the demonstration so just to
give you a sense of what these policies
look like here's a robot soccer policy
which is just trying to like intercept a
ball and score on the goal continuously
so it's actually quite effective you can
see
uh in a different domain for social
navigation so the blue box is a robot
given two different sets of
demonstrations though the synthesizer
can learn policies of different
characteristics so the the policy on the
upper side set is given demonstrations
of how to be socially compliant whereas
the one below is more aggressive and the
robot actually picks up on that right
um so how effective are these policies
the these synthesized policies are
actually quite effective so compared to
a reference policy our approach is
actually has comparable performance
success rate so 89 for the reference for
an attacker whereas ldips has 87
it outperforms an lstm based approach to
doing the same policy uh and
interestingly uh it actually outperforms
a dimension unaware synthesizer as well
so how uh
what else can this uh
approach of like symbolic program
synthesis give you so the next thing
that it gives you is data efficiency in
particular the number of time steps that
you need for corrections is extremely
small so it takes about 750 time steps
which is roughly 15 minutes of
demonstration to generate a policy which
is 87 accurate compared to many orders
of magnitude more time steps that you
actually need for to synthesize lstms
right
okay so you've synthesized the policy
let's say you did that in simulation and
you want to transfer it to the real
world so of course when you transfer a
policy to the real world things that
don't work quite so well the robot is
able to like intercept the ball but it's
not scoring or shooting for some reason
so what do you do all right so the
interesting thing is that if you have a
symbolic policy you can actually provide
corrections can correct these policies
with small numbers of demonstrations the
way this is done is that you have some
some corrections which is a log of what
were the inputs and when were the
corrections provided and then using some
automated analysis
the symbolic policy can be used to
construct sat formulae where the
essentially the sat formula saying can
you come up with adjustments delta
such that the result of running the
program at the time of the correction is
equal to the correction right and if you
solve the sat formula you found a
correction right
and this actually works quite well in
the same
failing case which i showed before
you're actually able to
like correct for the behaviors that
you've seen before you can also expand
to unexpected scenarios so i told you
about like the robot needing to wait for
the door to be open
um i'm just going to skip and show you
the before and after so the before is
the original policy where the robot
will go
obstinately all the way to the door and
like not wait for the door to be open
whereas with a few demonstrations uh
jarrett was able to convince a robot to
like if the door is closed wait for the
door to be open before you proceed uh so
in the first scenario the robot doesn't
hit the door it just like goes very
close and like prevents a human from
opening the door for it okay
so um this is actually a very whirlwind
overview of some of the things that
we've been doing to overcome the
challenges to long-term autonomy
i've spoken about approaches for
all the three things which i was going
to talk about and we're looking at like
many ongoing and future work directions
including thinking about do we even need
metric maps how can robots actively
experiment in the world to learn their
limitations how can we jointly optimize
for competency as well as competency
awareness
and how can we actually do uh
neurosymbolic program synthesis uh using
uh using perceptual tasks okay so i want
to thank my groups many of which uh i
showed photos off for the individual
algorithms but um this is a photo before
the pandemic during the pandemic we had
a virtual baking
event so that's us um you know having
fun baking
and uh
i want to thank uh my collaborators both
at ut and umass and elsewhere
and um i can take questions uh if you
have them uh if you have questions if
you're interested for papers videos and
code you can go to my website um and uh
take a look if you have questions feel
free to email me yes yeah so um given
links
given like these large areas that you're
working with like can you just like um
explain some of more you know the
techniques you're using to correct the
maps in more detail oh for the maps in
the real world
uh all right so several techniques so
first of all instead of thinking about
like low level features of like visual
features and like 3d points and all we
started thinking about the world in
terms of like the semantic entities
right so how are the semantic entities
distributed when things change what
objects have moved where right so this
is that that's actually the paradigm
shift which you're moving towards right
so
probabilistic reasoning at the level of
entities rather than these low level
features and there's a reason for that
uh these low-level features are not very
uh
are not very robust to like viewpoint
and lighting changes so the lighting
changes the the surf feature the zip
feature is going to be completely
different but guess what uh at low
lighting um i mean it might be harder
but still a chair is a chair
right so
it makes sense to think about the world
in terms of semantic and so this is
actually the key insight that we're
bringing to like how do you reason about
at scale of the world okay
um yes
okay other questions yes yeah for the
last set of slides i was
smt like solver method with uh the lstms
methods yep i think for me it's actually
not like too surprising that an lsd
would have of course complexity because
there's like way less structure yeah
like the benefit is like you can
generalize
a lot better right and like this smt
solver seems to be making like some
assumptions about uh like the downstream
tasks so i guess i'm curious if you ran
any ablations that radically change the
demonstrations maybe the human data
provided and then you ask the robot to
generalize zero shot to like a totally
different setup yeah so the question is
like uh what
in the lstm setting the lstm does not
have the benefit of things like the
dimension analysis and is missing the
context with the smt solver and like the
synthesizer is able to pick up on and
the question is like have you done
ablation studies to see how well these
things generalize um we did some of this
and we actually came up with a social
navigation gym environment where we did
extensive evaluation of both like uh
classical machine learning uh like deep
learning based approaches for learning
these policies as well as symbolic and
neurosymbolic approaches to them and uh
one way in which we looked at transfer
is that we we train them to do social
navigation like uh particular different
types of building floor plans and tested
them on a new set of building floor
plans um
it turns out that the symbolic
approaches are actually very good at
generalizing um
there's like different gradations of
like how well these learned approaches
generalized depending on whether they're
doing directly behavior cloning which is
not so good versus if you're doing
inverse reinforcement learning which
does slightly better um but but yeah we
have done some amount of that i can
point you to like the quantitative
results of that